Speaker 1: One of the things I truly love is when
a radical ideologue gets confused and doesn't
even understand their own rancid and disgusting
talking points. When I was interviewed by Jesse
Lee Peterson in Los Angeles a couple of years
ago, I had trouble not laughing when he would use
terrible, debunked talking points, but like
he would get them wrong about socialism and
other things. So today I have a clip for you
that's really emblematic of a lot of the COVID
disinformation that's floating around. Republican
Congresswoman Marjorie Taylor Greene has been a
big voice against vaccine requirements against
masks in favor of various unproven treatments
for COVID, including ivermectin. She appeared
on Real America's Voice recently and hilariously
hilariously claimed that ivermectin won a
Nobel Peace Prize. Now there's two layers
of confusion here. I won't explain
them yet. Let's look at the clip.
Speaker 4: Ivermectin is a very good drug. It's
safety nets that's been proven for decades. It
even won a Nobel Peace Prize, and it is absolutely
irresponsible for the Biden administration.
The CDC, Dr. Fauci and any of these doctors
to be advising people to not prescribe it.
Speaker 1: Isn't that just the best? So
two layers of confusion here. First of all,
ivermectin didn't win any Nobel Prize, and it
definitely didn't win a Nobel Peace Prize. There
are two scientists William Campbell and Satoshi
Omura won a Nobel Prize in 2015 for discovering
that a modified version of ivermectin
called ivermectin could be used
to treat infections caused by roundworm
parasites. Nothing about a Nobel Peace Prize,
nor anything about ivermectin to treat COVID,
so consider the fallacious reasoning here.
But this is the type of stuff these
right wingers love. They latch onto it.
Marjorie Taylor Greene says or implies we should
be giving ivermectin for COVID to people because
ivermectin won a Nobel Peace Prize. And then
you look at it. Ivermectin didn't win any prize,
especially not a peace prize. Two scientists won
a Nobel Prize in medicine for their discovery
that a different compound based on
ivermectin called ivermectin could be used
specifically for treating roundworm. And her view
is Nobel Peace Prize. Give it to people for COVID,
but it just gets repeated and repeated. You
hear it once ivermectin won a Nobel Peace Prize
or Nobel Prize, and suddenly you hear the talking
point everywhere and it is everywhere. It spreads
uncontrollably without any real investigation. The
reason Marjorie Taylor Greene got in trouble here,
by the way, is that Nobel Peace Prize is
like a little too much. So there's been
more fact-checking like really a Nobel Peace
Prize that doesn't that doesn't make sense.
Had she simply said Nobel Prize, this would almost
certainly have continued to spread without even
more fact checking of it done, which fortunately
did take place. Sadly, her reelection is likely
to happen. She's in a very red district. Back in
February March, there were articles saying, Oh,
she's got a tough, uphill battle. Big primary
challenger. As far as I was able to find this
morning, no serious Republican primary challenger
to Marjorie Taylor Greene. And it is not looking
good at all. So we may well be dealing with
another two years of Marjorie Taylor Greene
and another two years of exactly this type
of just humiliating, humiliating nonsense.